at airports across the country thousands
protested president Trump's executive
order banning refugees and residents of
seven predominantly Muslim countries
from entry to the United States in
Silicon Valley the order sent ripples
through the diverse tech industry which
has long relied on immigrant talent and
entrepreneurship having news like that
just makes you wonder are you what what
country you're in this is what we'd
expected it was kind of that we came
from but not the US who's saying Kasai
is the Iranian British CEO of on Fido an
identity verification company based in
London and expanding in San Francisco
for him the order was a message that his
startup is likely to be very different
and difficult under Trump so one of my
co-founders he is actually Iraqi and he
is now potentially not able to come over
here which creates another issue you
know how can you have two co-founders
not being mobile in the sense that we
have been so this is just the beginning
of the disruptions disruption is usually
a positive thing in tech but the order
and the White House is leaked plans to
tighten restrictions on a visa called
the h-1b but the industry on high alert
an h-1b visa is a visa for professional
workers who are working in what the
government considers to be a specialty
occupation 65% of the h-1b visas issued
in 2013 went to computer related jobs
positions that could now be in jeopardy
immigration law offices like galley
Gordon's have been flooded with calls
from nervous clients it's incredibly
anxiety provoking not only for
immigrants but for non-immigrant
employees who are here for for companies
that are trying to hire them you know
you can see in the way that the
government rolled out the travel ban
that it was done very haphazardly one
would hope that whatever reforms are
going to be brought forth are going to
be done in a much more thoughtful way
Tuukka side the White House's
immigration plans are a short-sighted
attempt to combat terrorism and boost
American productivity well myself and
my two co-founders were migrants and
we've come over and in the US only in
the last year we've created two ten ten
jobs our product is all around carrying
out identity verification to prevent
customers signing up to banks or payment
platforms or others looking to launder
money that funds terrorism why would it
prevent the progress of the tech
community yet our technology or others
by hindering what what is so important
to it and that is access to talent and
people to hire from some tech leaders
have been pushing back Google co-founder
Sergey Brin who fled Russia as a child
joined protests at the San Francisco
Airport immigrants like Brynn have
founded more than half of the country's
billion dollar startups when I think of
my clients who are primarily not
exclusively but primarily tech companies
and they are hiring h-1b workers they're
sponsoring h-1b workers at almost
uniformly six-figure salaries picking in
another five six thousand dollars to pay
fees for an h-1b process so these are
not people who are looking for a cheaper
deal they are really looking to hire the
best and the brightest and and that's
why the h-1b visa program is essential
but the damage to Silicon Valley
entrepreneurship may already be done we
want to be him we want to grow here all
the things that contributed to the this
the Bay Area being so great diverse open
if those are now blocked then you may
not have a future as bright as we have
had over the last few decades